so after months and months and months
and months
and months seven months lawmakers have
finally agreed to a second coronavirus
stimulus
and they have not yet voted on it
they've agreed on it the house and
senate still need to vote on it but in
this story
i'll tell you everything that you might
be getting
and also what big business is getting
and what nobody's getting which is very
very important um sadly this is
mostly too little too late like if you
want to just click off and go to a
different story it's mostly too little
too late and you'll see why
momentarily uh but let's dig into it
this the the package in total is 900
billion dollars
it will include 600 payments to adults
earning up to 75 000
with the possibility of an additional
600 per dependent child
living at home although the language and
the specifics on that
may still change it's not completely
clear
restarted enhanced unemployment will be
in place
for 300 per week for 11 weeks remember
the original enhanced unemployment was
600 a week this will be
300 a week there will be 284
billion dollars for businesses the ppp
program will be restarted there will be
expanded eligibility
uh for nonprofits newspapers radio and
tv
broadcasters 15 billion for performance
venues and independent movie theaters
which are essentially
shut down in total uh save some rare
examples that have figured out how to do
sort of uh like mask required everybody
gets tested on the way in
types of things there will be money for
testing and tracing
82 billion dollars for colleges and
schools which many people have an issue
with
uh the the idea of some of these largely
well-endowed schools getting money when
they don't even really need to be
charging tuition they could pay for
everybody's tuition with the interest on
their endowments
that's a problem for some 13 billion
dollars for nutritional assistance 7
billion
for broadband access 25 billion for
rental assistance
and an extended eviction moratorium so
basically
it's too little too late and the devil
is in the details with a lot of these
line items for example
just to pick one seven billion dollars
for broadband support
how exactly does that work is it just a
cash grab
for isps is it actually reimbursements
for people who sign up for internet
service what how is that that all
it's all in the in the details because
these programs can either be beneficial
or slush funds for big corporations or
both admittedly it can be it can be both
now is it better than nothing well yeah
of course of course
uh with the caveat that sometimes doing
something crappy is used as an excuse to
not do anything else
so if i have a gunshot wound and you
hand me a band-aid is the band-aid
better than nothing if more help is
coming well yeah it might be the
band-aid might do something for me
for two minutes until we get real
treatment
but if handing me the band-aid is all we
do well then i'm going to be screwed
and it's been seven months since the
last uh
stimulus package people are getting half
the cash payment
and half the enhanced unemployment and
now
i i've been getting voicemails over the
weekend from people
who seem to think the reason i'm i did a
segment last week advocating for more
there's people who seem to think i'm
advocating for more so that i will get
more of something i i i don't even know
that i need to do this but i will
mention
that i am getting nothing i got nothing
last time
and neither did my business i'm getting
nothing this time
and neither is my business i'm not
arguing for even a single dollar for
myself i'm getting zero either way
so the it's half the benefits for people
as as the first time half the money is
the first time
uh and then the unemployment benefits
are
half as big and they last for only 11
weeks about three months so
this all counts on a dramatically strong
recovery that will be in full swing
by march and things should be better by
then um as it starts getting warmer
again
and people start being vaccinated at a
higher rate
but expecting anything approaching a
full recovery by by three months from
now seems very silly
uh some industries won't be fully
recovered for years it is believed
a huge portion of small businesses are
never reopening people are making zero
right now so much like i said before
this was put together uh uh you know if
you're really struggling
600 isn't going to do much for you at
all it's been seven months you get 600
bucks it's not enough for a month's rent
in almost any part of the country
the unemployment payments won't be
retroactive so if you've been out of a
job for the last
several months um that that's just gone
uh
too bad it's not retroactive and there
are some on the right who are saying you
should be grateful that you got anything
the government doesn't owe you anything
600 is 600 more than the government owes
you well
the the idea of owing is sort of strange
but consider that the government allowed
the pandemic to get this bad in the
first place
one of the worst responses in the world
from the trump administration
and now it's everyone else who should be
grateful that they'll get 600 bucks
which is of course paid out of our own
tax money remember
despite it being the government's fault
that this got so bad in the first place
and had the government handled this
properly in a better way we wouldn't
even need the degree of stimulus that's
now needed and then on the tail end of
this
just the last thought that i have on
this uh calling it a rescue package is
almost laughable
but there is some aspect of this that
makes me wonder
is mitch mcconnell and are republicans
all of a sudden ready to get this done
quickly
because they believe it will help kelly
lefler and david perdue in georgia and
what i mean by that is
we've had the 2020 election trump lost
biden won
okay democrats retained control of the
house albeit by
a smaller margin than they had after the
2018 election
but control of the senate is still a
question mark control of the senate
senate is still up for grabs
and it will depend on these two runoff
elections on january 5th in georgia
is this an attempt to say hey look
lefler and purdue
delivered 600 bucks to you and more
unemployment money even to many vote
voters in georgia republican georgia
voters who don't even think the
government should be giving people
anything
is that part of the calculation here i
don't know
uh that that you know with mitch
mcconnell it's
the answer is it's likely so it's been
agreed upon
it's not yet been voted on we'll follow
the the process
up to actually being approved if it will
be and then of course who knows how many
weeks or months it would be until people
actually get any money
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress at home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video